rwanda is ready
50 rooms are waiting for the first
asylum seekers to arrive from the uk
we have a
twin room meaning that each room has a
capacitor accommodating to a person
the manager wants them to feel at home
he's tried to think of everything they
might need
the signs are in english and arabic
there's a prayer room
two computer centers and a gift shop
we have some
different things like
clothes and cigarettes as as you know
they like a cigarette yes
this is their home table they really
live in a good condition
the asylum seekers are free to leave any
time
this isn't a detention center it's their
first home in rwanda
paid for by the uk government in a deal
worth 120 million pounds for rwanda it
has to start at some point so this is
the beginning and you know more about
the cost per refugee
in this scheme
it will be about
about the same
that the uk spends on
on accommodating and processing migrants
this scheme isn't actually saving money
these are people so they have to be
accommodated in unsafe dignified
facilities and
that this investment ensures that
that they get treated with respect
[Applause]
rwanda already hosts asylum seekers the
people coming from the uk will not be
the first
[Music]
40 miles away from the capital off the
beaten track is this safe haven a
temporary home for people the u.n
refugee agency have brought here from
libya
refugees who have taken dangerous
journeys trying to get to europe the
refugees here have similar experiences
to the ones coming from the uk but
there's a big difference ones here are
hoping for resettlement in places like
canada or sweden the ones coming from
the uk have a one-way ticket rwanda is
their final destination
peter fled war in south sudan and
torture at the hands of people smugglers
the un have found him a new home in
finland
it is our last hope that we should be in
a free world one day if i would be
prepared to stay here one day i better
go back to libya did you think about
staying in rwanda i never i never and i
will not do that and it would be a last
mistake to do so
more than a thousand people have come
through this transit camp in the last
three years
they have three choices resettling in
another country returning home or
staying in rwanda
so far no one has chosen rwanda
the asylum seekers arriving here will
feel the same
thrust into a new country with no choice
but people here are confident that
rwanda is a place they will call home
a place where they can build a future
shinki marike sky news kigali